Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Gianni Infantino, seines Zeichens FIFA-Präsident, findet die WM in Russland ganz, ganz dufte und hat das natürlich auch genauso kommen sehen. Wir wollen diese Aussage einem Realitätscheck unterziehen und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost. Ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich hier in einem Tribünengespräch mit zwei Menschen auf die WM zu blicken, die auch vor Ort waren und die uns ein bisschen andere Perspektiven bringen können und wo wir das dann eben mal abgleichen. Mit deren Sicht auf diese Weltmeisterschaft. Deswegen begrüße ich bei mir zum einen mit seinem Rasenfunk-Debüt Nils Arnold et Grummelgru auf Twitter. Er war als Fan vor Ort bei der Weltmeisterschaft. Servus, Nils. Und außerdem mit dabei, Hendrik Buchheister et ha-Buchheister auf Twitter. Freier Sportjournalist, lebt eigentlich in UK und war jetzt vier Wochen lang in Russland. Hallo, Hendrik. Ich freue mich auch gleich mit euch noch mal einen etwas anderen Blick auf diese Weltmeisterschaft zu werfen. Schließt so ein Turnier immer ganz schön ab. Bevor wir damit loslegen, möchte ich aber schnell noch ein paar Menschen danken. Nämlich zum einen Achim, Moritz, Hendrik. Das ist nicht der Hendrik, der hier zugeschaltet ist. Julia und Julius. Sie sind alle Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wegen läuten wir euch. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Wer uns etwas unterstützen möchte, erfährt alles, was er dazu wissen muss. Auf rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Das soll es aber genug der Vorrede gewesen sein. Jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, Nils, erzähl uns doch mal kurz. Wie warst du denn jetzt bei der Weltmeisterschaft? Wie lange warst du da? Wie viele Spiele hast du gesehen? Fass mal kurz zusammen, bevor wir dann ins Detail gehen.
Ja, aber das finde ich da schon total fehl genannt, was das halt erklärt, dass dann gerade in der K.o.-Runde die Stadien leer sind. Und ich kannte diesen Eindruck. Max wurde auch gefragt, hast du wieder unser Eindruck? Weil diesen Eindruck habe ich auch bestätigt. Es waren schon viele Spiele, wo die Stadien vergleichsweise leer aussahen. Also dieses Ugoa gibt sicher das Extrembeispiel. Da war ich auch und da war die Stimmung wirklich traurig. Aber ich kann mich auch erinnern, jetzt beim Halbfinale in St. Petersburg, Belgien gegen Frankreich, da waren auch wahnsinnig viele freie Plätze, so wie ich das gesehen habe. Und wir haben ja schon gesagt, die Franzosen, da waren es nicht so wahnsinnig viele Leute dabei gehabt. Und bei den Belgiern war es irgendwie ähnlich. Dann ist dieses Stadion, 65.000 Leute gehen da rein. Das muss man halt auch erstmal voll kriegen. Ja, und glaube ich, so kommen dann irgendwie viele Gründe zusammen. Und beim Spiel um Platz drei war es dann das gleiche. Also wieder in Langpetersburg. Und da kommt dann einfach zu, es ist ein Spiel um Platz drei. Es ist ein besseres Freundschaftsspiel. Vielleicht sogar ein schlechteres Freundschaftsspiel. Aber dass dann Leute sagen, dafür gebe ich jetzt nicht noch mal einen dreistelligen Betrag aus, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Naja, 98 Prozent. Ich will nur noch mal die Zahl genannt haben. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr da gesehen habt. Was wir da beobachtet haben. Aber gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass es in Russland während der WM WM-Stadion gab mit Alkoholgehalt, was es sonst nicht gibt. Da wird wohl der eine oder andere von euch regelmäßig zu tief in den Becher geschaut. Es tut mir leid, dass ich das jetzt hier mal so öffentlich sagen muss. Was war denn die Stadt, die euch am meisten in Erinnerung bleiben wird? Nils, fang mal an.
Schwer zu sagen. Meistens sind es immer dann auch die Mädchen von den Stadien ab, aber auch von den Städten, was ich da dran so erlebe. Ich habe da komplett verschiedene Erfahrungen gemacht. Wie gesagt, ich treffe immer Leute beim Reisen, die ich immer wieder mal treffe. Und die sagen, die Stadt ist toll, da komme ich dahin, fand ich die nicht so toll. Und andersrum. Ich fand Kaliningrad nicht so toll, da gab es ein bisschen mehr, aber ich dachte, okay, früher Richtung Ostpreußen, das könnte interessant sein. Fand ich nicht so toll. Ich fand Nizhinovka dort auch sehr interessant. Mir hat es sehr gefallen mit dem Kreml, das eigentlich fast in jeder Größe Stadt geht. Also diese Festung, wo man über die Wolga gucken kann und so, fand ich es. Oder über die Flüsse gucken kann, das finde ich immer sehr toll. Moskau ist ein Moloch, da muss man nicht zu WM gehen. Da kann man sich so mal in Ruhe angucken. Das kommt mir auch so mal hin. Aber ich finde es immer toll, in Städte zu gehen, wo man sonst wirklich nicht hinkommen würde, wenn man nicht zum Turnier gehen würde. Und so gesehen hat mir Wolgo gerade sehr gut gefallen. Denn erstens hat mich die Vergangenheit interessiert, muss ich auch zugeben. Das spricht, ich bin auch dann ins Weltkrieg-Museum gegangen. Und man weiß auch die Bedeutung für Russland vom großen Vaterländischen Krieg. Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Wie ist es, wenn man da als Deutscher ist?
Bei mir ist der Punkt, ich sehe nicht aus wie ein Deutscher und ich trete nicht auf wie ein Deutscher, deswegen habe ich das nie so wahrgenommen. Ich wollte nie als Deutscher bezeichnet, deswegen weiß ich gar nicht. Ich kann leider nicht mitreden, muss ich zugeben. Das Thema selbst, Politik, kann ich mal ganz kurz anreißen. Ich hatte mit einem, wie gesagt, der hat auch als Archivar gearbeitet, also durchaus ansprechende Diskussionen. Aber ich habe irgendwann das Thema dann fallen gelassen, denn es ging dann darum, warum unterstützt Merkel Putin nicht? Das ist doch offensichtlich, die Krim gehört zu uns und so weiter und so fort. Das war mir dann ein bisschen zu heil. Ich kenne uns da alle ein bisschen aus, habe es gelassen. Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, die wollten, jeder will in jedem Land, wo er ist, die Leute wissen, und gefällt dir Russland, ich finde das auch so toll. Und das habe ich auch gern bejaht, denn es hat mir eigentlich überall gefallen, muss ich zugeben. Ansonsten fand ich eben Volgograd so toll, weil das Wetter toll war, weil ich da mal zwei Tage war am Stück war und nicht gleich weitergereist bin, weil ich eben dieses Stadion auch schön war und da an der Wolga gelegen. Und da oben drüber auch, wahrscheinlich kennt ihr diese Mutter-Russland-Statue, die dann nach dem Krieg gebaut wurde. Und das hat so einen Streik, man konnte auch hochlaufen, sich das angucken, dann oben schön auf die Stadt blicken und auf der Stadion. Mir hat es sehr gut gefallen. Und auch die Geschichte, die hinten dran war, und das war schon sehr, wie ich sage, berührend, aber wenn man sich das vorstellt, 70, 80 Jahre davor, und was da passiert ist, und dann stehen wir hier und feiern, fand ich schon sehr, sehr krass. Ich weiß nicht, ob alle Leute das so gesehen haben, aber deswegen bin ich auch ins Museum rein. Und ich muss auch sagen, die Deutschen, die ich alle getroffen habe, die wollten auch alle ins Museum rein, sind auch ins Museum reingegangen. Die wollten das auch sehen, das Weltkrieg, das Museum, und durchaus Interesse an dem ganzen Paar. Ich meine, das ist ja auch sehr präsent. Ich meine, man sieht überall in der Stadt noch, wie gerade die Leningstadion, aber davon abgesehen auch oft noch Panzer, die grün lackiert sind und noch dastehen, oder wie oft hat jetzt jede Stadt ein Militärmuseum und so. Also dem gesehen weiß man schon, was Bedeutung das von der russischen oder zivilischen Identität hat.
Hendrik, an was wirst du dich wahrscheinlich noch länger erinnern, an welche Orte?
Ja, also kann ich erstmal genauso unterstreichen, was du, Nils, gesagt hast, zur Bedeutung des Zweiten Weltkriegs für Russland und diese Präsenz, die das halt noch in gewisser Form hat. Also alles, was du jetzt gesagt hast, habe ich genauso auch wahrgenommen. Ohne jetzt selbst in Wolberg gewesen zu sein. Von den Städten, die mir am meisten Erinnerungen bleiben, also ich meine, klar, Moskau zu sagen, ist irgendwie einfach. Moskau ist, wenn man hier ist, schon eine sehr beeindruckende Stadt. Aber da kommt man tatsächlich immer mal irgendwie hin. Von den Städten, die ich jetzt noch nicht, oder ich war vorhin schon einmal in Moskau gewesen, ich kannte das zumindest so ein bisschen. Von den Städten, in denen ich noch nie gewesen bin und ja, wo man vielleicht auch abseits von, wo man halt nicht um den hinkommt, fand ich auch nicht in die Nordkorea tatsächlich am besten. Weil dieser Blick über diese beiden Flüsse, das hatte schon echt was. Man hat dann so auch Richtung Stadion geschaut und von dem hohen Ufer auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite, das war schon wirklich beeindruckend. Ich habe da irgendwie ein paar echt nette Restaurants und Bars irgendwie gefunden, in denen ich dann Fußballspiele mir angeschaut habe. Ich habe eine Bar gefunden im Hinterhof, da habe ich mir das Englern-Kolumbienspiel angeschaut und da haben dann plötzlich alle Leute für England gejubelt. Man dachte auch irgendwie, es hieß doch, dass die Russen die Engländer nicht mögen. Also wo man dann auch so einen Reality-Check bekommt und dann merkt, es ist natürlich alles viel schichtiger, als man sich vorher irgendwie vorgestellt hat. Also von daher, was die Stadt an sich und aber auch die Leute und die Sachen, die man da so machen konnte, anging, da fand ich auch nicht aufgehört wirklich. Das wird auf jeden Fall in Erinnerung bleiben. Ich hab am letzten Tag eine Fahrt mit der Seilbahn über die Volga gemacht. Und wenn man dann noch mal merkt, was die Volga für ein wahnsinnig breiter Fluss ist, dass man mit dieser Seilbahn irgendwie 20 Minuten unterwegs ist, das ist unfassbar. Aber wirklich so, ja, das sind so Sachen, die erlebt man halt so schnell nicht wieder. Und von daher wird das absolut in Erinnerung bleiben.
Und welches war das schönste Stadion? War das bemerkenswerteste? Gut, über je Katharinenburg haben wir jetzt schon gesprochen.
Dürfen wir das nicht mehr nennen? Naja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin nicht unbedingt ein Fan von diesen hypermodernen Stadien. Aber wenn ein Stadion irgendwie so richtig groß ist und wie eine beeindruckende Aura hat, dann finde ich das schon spannend. Diese Stadion in St. Petersburg erschlägt einen, weil das so riesig ist, weil da oben noch diese Spitzen drauf sind, die über das Stadion hinausragen. Und wir wissen noch alle, wie wahnsinnig viel das gekostet hat und was für eine Verschwendung das war. Aber das ist, wenn man dort ist, ein beeindruckendes Fußballstadion.
Also man sieht die Verschwendung wenigstens auch.
Man sieht die Verschwendung auch. Und ich fand auch Luschniki wirklich ein sehr schönes Stadion. Auch ein sehr würdiges Finale-Stadion.
Also ich kann mich da eigentlich nur anschließen. Luschniki war vor, mit einer leichter ledigen Laufbahn, also was sie draus gemacht haben, Respekt davor. Das haben sie echt super hinbekommen. Ich fand Jürgen Riedenburg hat dich schon gesagt, fand ich interessant. Ansonsten fanden halt diese Stadion weg, die zugleich waren. Also Kaliningrad zum Beispiel und Rostov am Don. Das waren einfach, Entschuldigung, wie man sich einfach kennt. Ansonsten, ja, also ich bin über jede Stadion und froh, was eine Geschichte hat. Ich fand auch interessant, Sochi ist natürlich der komplett künstliche Badeort. Also das sind nur kleine Orte, dieser Hartler ist der Hauptort nebendran. Aber was man zum Stadion sagen muss, es hat eine besondere Architektur. Deswegen ist es schon wieder interessant, in dem gewesen zu sein. Denn man erkennt das sofort, ich bis sofort, es leuchtet, das ist Sochi. Das kann ich bei anderen Stadionen halt nicht sagen. Das ist für mich nur so ein Kriterium, wo ich sage, okay, das Stadion hat was Besonderes.
Das war das Stadion, das so eine Muschelform im Entfernen hat.
Genau, so geöffnet ist es an den Seiten, wo sie aber auch so kleine mobile Tribünen noch reingestellt haben, wo sich dann Leute auch im Regen saßen, als es ein bisschen getröpfelt hat. Aber leider nichts topt je Katharinenburg, weil es hat wirklich was Spezielles.
Man wird schon ein bisschen neidisch auf euch, wenn man mit euch über eure vier Wochen Russland spricht. Das muss man schon mal sagen. Hendrik, was war denn so die netteste Reisebegebenheit, die du so hattest? Wir haben jetzt schon über Nachtzüge gesprochen, die im Schritttempo gefahren sind. Sicherlich bist du auch das eine oder andere Mal geflogen. Gab es da irgendwas, wo du denkst, okay, das wird wahrscheinlich für mich persönlich von dieser WM noch bleiben?
Da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen nachdenken. Also die Flüge liefen alle sehr reibungslos und unspektakulär. Ich weiß nicht, ob das als Reisebegebenheit zählt, weil eigentlich sind ja Taxi-Geschichten immer so, jeder erzählt Taxi-Geschichten, aber ich fand das Taxifahren in Russland war immer ein absolutes Spektakel, weil die Leute wahnsinnig schnell unterwegs sind, weil die in den Taxen dann auch immer irgendwie, denen war das halt egal, ob da jetzt Fahrgäste drin saßen, die haben trotzdem immer so Krawall-Techno gehört, die dann auch immer auf volle Lautstärke und dann halt irgendwie so über diese, irgendwie nachts um drei über diese breiten russischen Straßen, das hat ja schon was, das war schon irgendwie, das sind so Erlebnisse und die Leute waren total nett und haben auch versucht, in Gespräche zu verwickeln, auch wenn ihr gemerkt habt, man spricht kein Russisch, dann hat man sich halt irgendwie über Google Translate in Gespräche verwickelt, also das sind so, da fällt es mir jetzt schwer, diese eine Begebenheit rauszusuchen, aber diese Taxifahrten während dieser WM, WM, das sind schon Sachen, die bleiben oder wie hängen.
Nils, hast du da irgendwas erlebt?
Ja, also ich hab auch gar nicht groß erzählt, aber ich fand die Zugfahrten sehr toll. Ich muss sagen, ich hab mich auf die Zugfahrten immer gefreut, weil da lernt man auch die Leute kennen. Und nach so einem, meine Trips waren gar nicht so lange, weil sonst hätt ich's gar nicht geschafft mit den verschiedenen Stadien. Aber also maximal so 13, 14 Stunden Fahrten mit drinne. Und auch natürlich über Nacht. Aber ich hab Journalisten kennengelernt, mit denen ich dann aus Finnland die einfach gequatscht habe oder... Ich hab auch ganze Familien, russische Familien kennengelernt, die so stolz waren, dass sie ein Ticket für ein Spiel bekommen haben und dann zusammen hingefahren sind und das...
Und dann ist einer von denen in Stadion gegangen?
Nee, alle zusammen haben alle Tickets bekommen. Nee, das sind sie nicht. Aber auch, dann haben sich alle Trikots gekauft und zwar manchmal auch der Vater von dem einen Land, der Sohn von dem anderen Land. Dann konnte der Vater nicht Englisch, der Sohn hat es übersetzt, wenn er Englisch konnte. Und die waren sehr gastfreundlich, wollten alles mit dir teilen. Haben dir dann geholfen, wenn das im Zug unklar war. Das ist sehr angenehm und so stelle ich mir das auch vor. Und so fand ich das Reisen auch immer sehr angenehm. Also das bleibt im Kopf hängen. Genauso habe ich, glaube ich, auf einer Fahrt, da war ich beim Deutschland-Spiel und habe mich gleich weitergefahren zum Schwedenspiel, auch nach Nischi Novkrotn im Zug. Und habe dann Schweden kennengelernt im Zug. Und Skandinavier-Zufe sind immer sehr gut, die sprechen so gut Englisch und die haben so viel zu erzählen. Das war einfach eine angenehme Fahrt, mit denen über Gott und die Welt zu reden. Da habe ich über den letzten Turnier geredet, der war auch, hat er erzählt und so weiter. Allgemein ist, wenn man bei der WM reist, bei so einem Turnier und macht das mal dann so wie ich und geht es alleine an. Man ist nie alleine, man lernt so viele Leute kennen. Also ich habe in Hostels übernachtet, da habe ich die ganze Nacht durchgequatscht mit Jugendlichen aus allen möglichen Ländern, nicht nur von WM-Ländern, sondern auch aus Singapur, die einfach hingekommen sind und die WM sehen wollten. Und da lernt man, das ist das, was das Tolle an so einem Turnier hat. Also das vielleicht ein bisschen untergeht und vielleicht auch ein bisschen idealistisch oder so. Aber das finde ich sogar ein bisschen Völkerverständigung da, wo alle Spaß haben wollen und dann, selbst wenn sie nur ins Ferienfest gehen und ein bisschen trinken wollen oder was auch immer, man lernt sehr viele Leute kennen und die einfach nur Spaß haben wollen im Fußball. Und das ist schon sehr angenehm. Und die Sprachbarrieren, in Englisch gibt es die eigentlich nicht. Und beim Russen kann man die auch immer irgendwie umgehen. Und deswegen bleibt sowas immer hängen. Ganz viele Gespräche mit ganz vielen Leuten.
Ich muss sagen, das hört sich wirklich sehr gut an. Und hört sich so an, dass jenseits von all dem Commerz und all dem, was die FIFA da tut, um auch die Gastgeberländer zu gängeln und noch den letzten Euro rauszupressen, dann doch viel von dem noch bestehen bleibt, was eben einfach so Turniere auszeichnet. Dass man sich einfach mit Menschen aus ganz, ganz vielen Ländern trifft und ganz interessante Erfahrungen macht und einfach viel Neues entdeckt und das alles in einer schönen Atmosphäre, wo man alle das gemeinsame Interesse am Fußball teilt. Das hört sich schon wirklich eigentlich, hört sich wirklich gar nicht so weit weg von der Best World Cup Ever.
Wobei, dann kann man natürlich sagen, dann ist jeder World Cup der Best World Cup Ever, weil das ist ja einfach, das ist einfach das Wesen von so einer WM, dass man halt dort viele Leute aus der ganzen Welt auf einem vergleichbar kleinen Raum hat, die alle Bock auf Fußball haben und halt alle irgendwie gerade fremd dort sind, wo sie sind. Von daher ist das natürlich nicht Russland-spezifisch, aber ich habe das genauso empfunden. Also noch nie in so kurzen Zeitraum so viele Leute aus so vielen verschiedenen Ländern getroffen oder kennengelernt. Das macht dann schon auch, neben der ganzen Arbeit, macht es dann das doch extrem angenehm.
Gab es denn auch Vorurteile, die ihr jetzt nicht mehr habt und die ihr jetzt stellvertretend auch bei allen Hörern und Hörern aufbrechen könnt über Russland, über die russischen Menschen?
Also ich gehe immer davon aus, dass ich eben vor sechs Jahren in Polen in der Ukraine war und als die Auslösung war und hieß das Deutschland in der Ukraine spielt, ich habe gesagt, hm, ich habe keine Polen gesehen. Am Schluss war ich so froh, weil die Ukraine so toll war, weil die Leute toll fand und das Land. Deswegen war für mich auch klar, zu komplett verschiedenen kann Russland nicht sein. Deswegen wurde ich auch nicht enttäuscht. Und ich fand es auch toll, in Landzeiten, wo du siehst, die Leute sprechen eine andere Sprache, es ist eine andere Schrift, die kleiden sich anders, essen andere Sachen. Das macht es erst interessant, in Land zu reisen. Deswegen wurde ich auch jetzt nicht enttäuscht oder in eine andere Richtung. Mir ist nicht absolut klar, dass zum Beispiel, wenn ich mit Polizisten geredet habe, dass die anders auf mich reagieren als auf einen Einheimischen. Das wurde mir auch bestätigt und es ist auch so gewesen. Ich kann eine Geschichte erzählen, immer witzig, im Stadion haben sie mich darauf hingewiesen, dass ich doch bitte beim deutschen Spiel, als ich in der Sonne stand, mein Trikot wieder anziehen sollte. Und dann habe ich gesagt, warum denn? Dann habe ich gesagt, eine FIFA-Regel. Dann habe ich gesagt, nee, das sehe ich nicht ein. Dann sind noch dreimal kommende Voluntärer. Und irgendwann hat sie aufgeben, weil sie mir nichts sagen konnte. Ich glaube, wenn du sonst im Spiel bist und bei dem russischen Liga und dir dann irgendetwas, was du machen sollst oder nicht, und du legst dich dann mit dem an, dann tust du es besser ein. Dann macht man es auch nicht. Da haben auch Leute bestätigt, ich habe einmal einem Polizisten genau beim Eingang widersprochen, das fand er nicht so witzig. Da habe ich gefragt, warum das so ist. Und er sagt, wir wissen es ja nicht. Er hat es mir eindeutig zu verstehen gegeben. Ich will es gar nicht schlecht machen. Es geht nur, da habe ich mir gemerkt, okay, wir Fans, uns ging es da auch sehr gut, muss man sagen. Und das darf man nie vergessen. Also, ich meine, wir durften die U-Bahn umsonst benutzen. Wir, die Touristen, die das Geld haben, die Fans, die Einheimischen mussten für die U-Bahn-Tasse zahlen und haben weniger Geld. Also nur als Beispiel. Also, uns wurde schon sehr viel für uns gemacht. Ich gehe jetzt nicht direkt auf deine Frage ein, aber das ist bei mir so hängen geblieben eben. Und ansonsten, es gibt für mich keinen Grund jetzt, wenn man durch die Probleme, die man dir ausblendet, nicht nach Russland zu reisen, ein schönes Land, es gibt eine andere Kultur zu entdecken, was auch immer. Man muss ja mit sich vereinbaren, wenn man sagt, okay, ich will da nicht hinreisen, weil ich nicht den Herr Putin unterstützen will oder andere, aber dann dürfte man viele andere Länder auch nicht reisen, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Ja, du, ich lebe in Bayern also.
Ich sag's da auch in der Antlas-Ausfang. Genau, ja.
Ja, aber ich... Ey, du bist bald nicht mal mehr EU-Hendrik, also...
Ich würde mich da eigentlich genauso anschließen, dass natürlich, wenn man als Fan oder als Journalist dort unterwegs ist, ist man in einer privilegierten Stellung, weil man Sachen darf, wie der einheimische Russe, wenn nicht gerade die Menschen in Russland leben, wenn nicht gerade WM ist, nicht dürfen. Ich glaube, das, Max, hattest du in der Folge mit der Katrin Scheidt mal besprochen, als es zum Beispiel darum ging, was das Alkoholtrinken auf der Straße angeht und solche Sachen. Oder, Nils, wie du sagst, wir dürfen halt mit der U-Bahn kostenlos fahren. Die Leute, die dort leben, müssen halt für die U-Bahn zahlen. Von daher sind wir natürlich in einer absolut privilegierten Lage und es war klar, dass Russland alles dafür tun wird, ein möglichst gutes, freundliches, offenes Bild abzugeben. Und das war diese WM natürlich schon –es ist natürlich politische WM –so. Aber das vorausgeschickt waren die Erlebnisse, die man an Vorort hatte, alle absolut positiv. Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich groß mit Vorurteilen nach Russland gereist bin, aber mit Herr schon in Form von so gemischten Gefühlen. Von wegen mal gucken, wie das alles würde. Die Leute waren ausnahmslos nett, sehr, sehr hilfsbereit. Wurde auch schon von vielen anderen Leuten geschildert, die dort waren. Das sieht man, dass die Leute in Russland einfach sehr, sehr hilfsbereit sind. Ich hatte eine Situation in der U-Bahn. Da stand ich und jemand saß und meinte, ob ich mich setzen möchte. Weil ich halt gepackter war, meinte ich, alles gut. Ich bin noch in einem Alter, ich kann auch in der U-Bahn stehen. Ich meinte, wirklich, setz dich. Ich meinte, alles gut, wirklich. Dann bin ich stehen geblieben und dann ist eine Station weiter, eine Frau eingestiegen. Sie fragte dann auch, möchtest du dich setzen? Sie meinte auch, alles gut. Dann hat sie auf den Platz gesetzt, dass sie jetzt bitte sitzt. Ich hatte schon das Gefühl, dass diese Hilfsbereitschaft eine große Sache in Russland ist. Das bleibt auf jeden Fall hängen. Ansonsten sind die Städte spannend, die Architektur ist spannend, die Kultur ist spannend. Deswegen würde ich einfach sagen, wer da Lust hat, der sollte einfach mal nach Russland reisen und sich das angucken. Das hat der Kollege Paul Linke bei Twitter geschrieben. Dass es einfach immer hilft, um sich vielleicht ein etwas vollständiges Bild zu bilden, sodass negiert nicht die Probleme, die es gibt, aber es trägt einfach zu einem vollständigen Bild bei.
Über was wollen die Leute mit einem reden, wenn es mal nicht um Fußball geht? Klar, das wird das erste Thema sein. Aber interessiert die dann auch irgendwas Besonderes? Interessieren die sich für Politik oder wollen die wissen, wie ihr in den Ländern, in denen ihr gerade lebt, unterwegs seid? Nils, was waren so die Gespräche, die du geführt hast?
Also leider haben sich gar nicht so viele Gespräche ergeben. Prinzipiell ist es immer so, dass die Leute wissen wollen, wie einem Russland gefällt. Und da rede ich auch gerne drüber und sage auch, mir gefällt auch in Russland auch, dass es zum Beispiel nicht ganz so perfekt und sauber ist wie in Deutschland. Ich mag das lieber. Deswegen kenne ich auch gerne andere Länder, wo ich sage, es muss nicht um die Europaseite. Sage ich den Leuten auch, erkläre es denen, dann wundern sie sich drüber, weil sie finden das toll. Ich sage mir aber auch, zum Beispiel gesagt, dass das halt wirklich sehr, wie auch vorhin schon Hendrik erklärt hat, in diesem Innenraumbereich bei der FIFA, in den Städten war das extrem gekleant und sauber. Die Obdachlosen wurden beiseitegeschafft. Es muss man einfach sagen, es ist passiert. Es war einfach sauber und perfekt, aber es war schon zu sauber. Das ist mir hängen geblieben. Ansonsten habe ich mal eben, vorhin schon angedeutet, durch diesen Walk durch Moskau irgendwann Zeit gehabt, mit diesem Russen zu reden, der mir das erklärt hat, und der auch gebildet war und der eher so ausgedrückt hat, dass er meinte, dass er nicht versteht, warum der Westen, dieses schlechte Bild von Moskau und von Russland hat, und warum man nicht verstehen könnte, warum die Krim so lau war, und warum man nicht verstehe, dass es in Richtung Ostukraine so läuft. Das war schon interessant. Ich hätte gerne mit ihm darüber geredet, ich kenne mich da auch einigermaßen aus, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, wenn ich ihm wirklich meine Meinung sage, dann hätte ich ihn sehr verletzt. Das wollte ich dann auch nicht machen. Er war gerade an der Gaskäbe und wollte uns sein Land zeigen und war stolz auf Moskau. Das habe ich auch gerne mitgenommen. Daran wollte ich ihn wirklich nicht verletzen. Und ich glaube, das hätte ich schon getan, wenn ich gesagt hätte, das kann man aus zwei verschiedenen Perspektiven sehen. Ich habe es mal so formuliert im Tweet. Das Land ist halt riesig und so groß wie das Land ist, sind auch teilweise die Komplexe und der Stolz. Ich finde es ein ganz tolles Land. Die Flüsse sind riesig, die Gebäude, die Städte und der Stolz auch. Es kann auch viel Stolz sein, aber auch teilweise die Komplexe, die sie haben. Und das hat man schon auch gemerkt, wenn ich mit den Leuten länger mal unterhalten habe. Es war nicht oft der Fall, aber das hast du schon gemerkt. Und dann merkst du schon, dass das nicht alles in Ordnung ist zwischen Russland und vor allem Europa und so weiter. Das ist mir so hängen geblieben, wenn ich mit den Leuten darüber gesprochen habe.
Ja, das kann ich im Grunde nur so bestätigen. Max, du meintest ja, über was man gesprochen hat, wenn man nicht über Fußball gesprochen hat. Vielleicht muss man trotzdem noch einmal sagen, wenn man gesagt hat, man kommt aus Deutschland, dann war natürlich gleich, ach Deutschland, was war denn da los und woran hat es gelegen?
Schade, ist ja unglaublich und dann habt ihr gesagt, die haben nicht die Hunde mitgesungen, dann haben sie gesagt, ach so, ja klar, haben wir uns auch schon gedacht.
Genau, und falscher Hashtag. Also kann man nie so um Fußball ganz drum rum, aber ansonsten war das auch mein Eindruck, dass die Leute oftmals ein sehr wenig differenziertes Bild von gewissen Dingen haben. Und wenn man ihnen dann sagt, Nils, wie du meinst, das sehe ich immer komplett anders, aber das kann man doch auch anders sehen, dass sie das halt eben nicht sehen. Und dass man die Leute dann wahrscheinlich eher verletzt und dass man dann, ich weiß nicht, ob man da vielleicht auch eher konfrontativer sein müssen, aber dass man dann auch aus solchen Gesprächen sich dann eher zurückzieht und man dann eher sagt, okay, dann, aber Russland ist schön und die Städte sind toll. Hat man halt immer so was gesprochen. Und mal ganz ehrlich, das waren bei mir tatsächlich auch so die meisten Gespräche. Also es ging da selten richtig tief, sondern es war wirklich oft, was war es mit den Deutschen und wie gefällt es dir hier? Und da konnte ich dann jeweils sagen, gefällt es dir gut, aber bei den Deutschen habe ich den Rasenfunk empfohlen.
Na gut, das wird denen sehr geholfen haben. Aber finde ich natürlich trotzdem gut, vor allem bei so langen Zugreisen. Da habe ich vorhin schon gedacht, als du gesagt hast, 15 Stunden Zugreise, habe ich mir gedacht, geil, das ist ja fast der Rasenfunk-Royal.
Ja, aber ohne Telefonsignal natürlich.
Ach, gibt es ein Land, das noch schlechteres Netz hat als Deutschland?
Nein. Also in diesen Zügen war es tatsächlich so, wenn du nicht gerade irgendwo stehst oder in eine größere Stadt fährst, dann hatte ich das oft, dass ich tatsächlich keinen Signal hatte. Man war dann wirklich mal so 10 Stunden. Da muss man ja reden. Man war da wirklich schlafen. Aber man war dann wirklich so 10 Stunden mal in so einem Kommunikationsloch.
Das kenne ich nicht anders. Aber ich habe es auch geschätzt, weil ich tendenziell wahrscheinlich jetzt so oft am Handy bin und habe nicht gestört. Man konnte die tolle Landschaft angucken oder man konnte wie gesagt schlafen, wenn man es konnte wegen der Hitze. Oder auch mit Leuten reden. Also hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile. Ich fand es gar nicht so schlimm.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Also das war auch komplett wertneutral gemeint. Ich fand es auch okay, mal so ein bisschen einfach mit Leuten zu sprechen oder Musik zu hören oder eben nicht ständig irgendwie.
Ja, wäre eigentlich ganz gut für meinen Urlaub. Vielleicht fahre ich nach Russland. Ich hänge auch zu viel am Handy. Da kommen auch zu viele Notifications immer rein. Na ja, das sind First-Word-Problems, wie sie First-Wordiger nicht sein könnten. Ich finde eigentlich, dass wir ganz gut so einen Eindruck davon bekommen haben, was ihr vor Ort erlebt habt. Tolle Reisen, die ihr da hattet. Der eine beruflich, der andere privat. Und doch irgendwie sich ähnlich. Und in einem faszinierenden Land, das wir ja auch schon durch die ganze Sendung mit Kathrin Scheib gehört haben, mit der ich morgen auch noch mal einen Kurzpass aufnehmen werde. Das heißt, von der kriegen wir auch noch mal so einen Moskauer Blick auf, wie war jetzt diese WM insgesamt. Und dann haben wir, glaube ich, ein ganz rundes Paket geschnürt hier im Rasenfunk. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was ihr loswerden wollt? Rückblickend jetzt auf dieses Fußballturnier? Oder habt ihr alle Dinge erzählt, die euch auf dem Herzen lagen?
Nee, ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind durch alles irgendwie ganz gut durch und haben, glaube ich, so alles irgendwie angesprochen, was man da irgendwie zu sagen kann. Also natürlich ist jetzt die große Frage, was heißt das für dieses Land? Aber wenn es tatsächlich rumgeht, was hat man so erlebt? Ich glaube, irgendwie haben wir viel besprochen. Und ich fand das Nils Arnold aber total spannend, diese Fansicht zu sehen von jemandem, der als Fan so mal die WM unterwegs war.
Es ist vor allem interessant zu sehen, wenn wir drauf gehen, was in vier Jahren sein könnte, was dann los ist. Das wäre jetzt mal eine Abschlussfrage gewesen. Ja, Entschuldigung, das war nicht. Also was ich sagen würde, erstens, der Appell reißt, guckt es euch an, es ist immer lohnenswert, es hat sich in anderer Sicht, hat auch Hendrik ganz toll gesagt, das ist genau der Punkt, einen eigenen Eindruck zu verschaffen. Und zweitens, aus Fußballfansicht oder Traditionssicht weiß ich, wenn ich da hinreisen sollte, in vier Jahren, was da stattfinden wird. Eins ist für den Crown-Topper ein Paradies, weil er jeden Tag drei Spiele sehen kann, das letzte in Herz hüpft. Die Frage ist, was mache ich nach vier Tagen, weil ich alle Stadion durchhalbe und es gibt keinen Alkohol und es gibt keine Kultur, also nicht mich bösgemal übertrieben formuliert, was mache ich dann? Dann werden sich viele Fans noch an Russland zurückerinnern und denken, dass es ein Paradies war, das alles da zu entdecken gab. Ich will es nicht so schlecht machen, aber vielleicht werde ich auch ganz überrascht sein, wer weiß, keine Ahnung. Aber Russland ist immer eine Reise wert.
Aber du wirst auf jeden Fall wieder auch Katar mitnehmen?
Ich sage es für jeden Turnier, ich mache es nicht und dann mache ich es doch. Alle lachen über mich und glauben mir sowieso nicht mehr. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ich mir da keine vier Wochen sein werde. Wenn Hendrik da arbeiten muss, hat er wahrscheinlich kurze Wege. Das wird toll für ihn sein. Die Frage ist, ob er jeden Abend gleich Tage an einer Hotelbar sich einen Abendtrink genehmigen möchte, der immer gleich ist. Das weiß ich nicht. Es gibt was zu sehen, auf jeden Fall. Ich fahre viel mal nach Oman rüber und sonst was. Es gibt viel zu sehen, aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, da war dann Russland wahrscheinlich noch das Paradies dagegen.
Genau, das sind ja noch viereinhalb Jahre Zeit, sich das zu überlegen, ob man das dann macht. Aber ich finde auch, das haben mir noch andere Kollegen gesagt oder geschrieben, dass Russland vielleicht schon die letzte WM war, wie man sie kannte, also in dem ganzen Land und auch im Sommer. Und es wird in der Katar natürlich alleine schon wegen dieser beiden Aspekte. Nicht sagen, dass es nicht noch andere, aber wegen dieser beiden Aspekte wird es eine ganz andere WM.
Ja, mal gucken. Dann wird natürlich die Nordamerika, Mittelamerika-WM noch kommen. Wenn ihr mich fragt, kommt dann China. Das könnte natürlich dann wieder interessant werden, wenn man da dann auch die Möglichkeit hat, viel zu sehen. Aber zwischendrin haben wir... Genau, über die wollte ich gerade noch sprechen. Also wenn man jetzt eure Geschichten hört, was ihr so erlebt habt und was ihr von diesem Land zu erzählen habt, finde ich es irgendwie noch dramatischer, dass es jetzt diese aufgebrochene Euro gibt. Es kann auch sein, dass es besser ist, dass man vielleicht noch mehr sieht. Aber vom Gefühl her, in meinem Kopf ist es noch nicht so ganz rein, dass das eine EM ist, die über ganz Europa verteilt ist. Und so schön das Signal sein mag. Aber ich glaube, irgendetwas wird fehlen.
Ich ringe da auch noch mit mir, ob ich das jetzt, wie ich das finden soll. Ich finde, das widerspricht natürlich ganz krass so einem Turniercharakter, wie man das kennt, dass die Turniere, dass das Turnier in einem Land ist, dass man dadurch immer so auch über die, ob am Fernsehen oder vor Ort so ein bisschen was mitbekommt über Land und Leute. Und das fällt natürlich da komplett weg. Andererseits kann man natürlich auch sagen, ob du jetzt in Russland 15 Stunden im Zug fährst, oder ob du mit Billigflieger irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, 3 Stunden von München nach Bucharest fliegst, macht da wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht mehr so den großen Unterschied. Ich ringe da auch noch so ein bisschen mit mir, wie ich das finden soll.
Da habe ich eigentlich Geiz hinzuzufügen. Ich glaube, da wird nicht diese Turnierstimmung aufkommen, wie es wird. Ich finde, es wird es nicht komplett verteufeln. Es soll nur einmalige Sache sein. Vor allem ist es auch interessant für Länder, wo niemals eine EM bekommen wird. Ob es jetzt gleich Aserbaidschan ist oder sowas, die kriegen ein Spiel, das finde ich schon mal toll. Aber dieses Flair wird komplett flöten gehen, weil wenn ein Spiel in Deutschland ist, dann ist ja nicht in ganz Deutschland EM-Stimmung, glaube ich. Also nichts, wenn man es vergleicht, zum Beispiel mit der WM 2006. Und das ist schon schade, würde ich schon sagen. Aber auch da vielleicht läuft es ja ganz anders. Ich bin da ja kein Prophet, ich weiß es nicht.
Genau. Ich meine, du wirst da eh nicht hingehen. Dann sprechen wir nach der EM dann, wie es dann war. Ach ja, als du jetzt Aserbaidschan gesagt hast, da hätte ich jetzt fast schon wieder ein Fass aufgemacht. Das ist ja sportpolitisch und unpolitisch an sich auch nochmal ein ganz eigenes Ding. Aber das wollen wir jetzt nicht berühren. Es gab auch genügend negativ Berichterstattung, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, hier im Rasenfunk. Ich habe auch viel hinter die Kulissen von FIFA und ähnlichen Konstrukten geguckt. Jetzt haben wir mal so ein bisschen das, was Gianni Infantino im Intro gesagt hat, mit euren Erfahrungen abgedeckt. Und ich muss sagen, es war hochspannend, euch zuzuhören. Und ich bin ein bisschen neidisch über die Erfahrung, die ihr sammeln konntet. Meine WM-Erfahrung deckt sich mit dem, was ich jetzt gerade hier erlebe. Ich stehe an meinem Schreibtest und vor mir läuft das Aufnahmeprogramm. Das war meine WM. Meine WM-Erinnerung. Die längste Reise, die ich unternommen habe, war von hier einen Stockwerk runter ins Schlafzimmer. Und dann bin ich dort ins Bett gefallen. Ist auch was Besonderes. Naja, nein, nein, nein, ich wollte mich nicht beschweren. Es ist ja schön, dass man für Fußballgucken dann irgendwie auch noch Geld verdienen kann damit. Und ja, das zum Beruf machen kann, brauche ich dir, Hendrik, ja auch nicht zu erzählen. Das ist ja... We are living the dream.
Es ist natürlich... Ich will es natürlich in keiner Form irgendwie klein machen, weil bei so einer WM unterwegs zu sein und so eine Reise mitzuerleben und bei einer WM-Finale zu sitzen, das ist natürlich großartig. Aber andererseits ist es natürlich auch Arbeit. Und natürlich auch in einer gewissen Form anstrengend. Von daher, wie gesagt, ohne das kleinreden zu wollen. Aber es ist auch total okay, dass die WM vorbei ist. Ich freue mich, dann wieder nach Hause zu kommen. Aber diese Erfahrung, das war absolut grundreifig.
Nee, das stimmt. Aber das kommt auch, glaube ich, nicht weinerlich rüber. Das versteht auch, glaube ich, jede Hörerin und jeder Hörer. Wenn man sagt, also nach vier Wochen arbeiten rund in diesem Umfeld, reicht es dann auch allein heute, dieses Gefühl zu haben, dass kein Spiel mehr ist. Das war irgendwie... Also mich hat es wirklich ein bisschen befreit, wo sie sagt. Ich bin gedacht, ach cool, heute kann ich um 20 Uhr meine Sendung aufnehmen und muss nicht irgendwas gucken. Wie praktisch ist das denn? Naja, ich danke euch beiden sehr. Das war wirklich sehr, sehr spannend. Vielen, vielen Dank an Nils Arnold et Grummelgroh auf Twitter. Ich hoffe, du kriegst jetzt jede Menge Follower. Du postest immer ganz schöne Bilder. Man kann da einiges erleben. Vielen, vielen Dank, Nils, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen, vielen Dank auch an euch. War sehr auch interessant, die Position von Hendrik zu hören. Und auch voll interessant, dass sie sich schon zum großen Teil gedeckt hat. Das fand ich schon sehr interessant. Ja, hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank.
Das freut mich. Und vielen Dank an Hendrik Buchheister, freier Sportsportanalyst als et ha- Buchheister auf Twitter. Hendrik, danke dir und dann einen guten Rückflug zurück in den Urlaub. Nee, nicht zurück in den Urlaub. Also ich wollte erst sagen zurück nach Hause, aber du hast noch Zeit, dass du weiter in den Urlaub fliegst. Also genieße dann auch die freien Tage. Ach wunderbar, dann fanden wir das alle interessant. Ich hoffe, ihr auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für euer Interesse. Das war es jetzt fast mit der WM-Berichterstattung im Rasenfunk. Morgen wird noch ein letzter WM-Kurzpass erscheinen und dann ist die WM auch hier im Rasenfunk offiziell vorbei und damit dann auch eigentlich erst so wirklich die WM vorbei. Im Grunde läuft sie gerade noch. Das wissen bloß viele nicht. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. rasenfunk.de unterstützen ist die Zauberurl. Bis bald mal wieder. Macht's gut, tschau. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.